المشهد اختلف هنا
والحطب فعلت هذا
حرائق المفتاح على وقطع للاشجار المعمره
والنادره تحت جنح الظلام عرى هذه الاحراج
وقلص الغطاء الاخضر الذي تتميز به جبال
عكار اقصى شمال لبنان قديما كان الاجداد
يدفون باشعال الحطب ولكن اي حطب
من الطبيعه من ارضه او من اي شيء بس للاسف
هذا الوضع الصعب حاليا ااه قلب هذا الوضع
ليكون في مافيات خاصه بالحطب هذه المافيات
مش عم تقطع شجره بتبيض
عم بهدد على التنوع البيولوجيا عم يخسرنا
مواطن للنباتات للحشرات
قطع الاشجار الطاقه
500 او قوسين بده يجيب مين معه ليش قادر
يجيبه بدنا نقعد بالحريمي ما في الا هيك
وعيد الى ربنا يدبره تنشدوا الجمعيات
البيئيه والبلديات ضمن امكاناتها المحدوده
لوقف المجازر بحق الطبيعه والبشر على
السواء لكن المافيات وتجار السوء لا حدود
لجشعهم لصباح العربيه رينادويه عكار